some breaking news reaching us here at  Sky Centre the footballer emiliana is  seller and his pilot David Abbott stone  had been exposed to harmful levels of  carbon monoxide in the cockpits of their  private plane when it crashed in the  English Channel on the 21st of January  this year that according to the Air  Accident Investigation Bureau  they said that prior to the crash the  cockpit had filled with the deadly gas  the body of 28 year old sailor was  recovered after being spotted inside the  downed aircraft at the bottom of the  English Channel the pilots body has  never been found blood tests van Salah  had been exposed to extremely high  levels of carbon monoxide